it all began here at this live food
market in Wuhan China a mysterious virus
born in its shops triggering a wave of
illnesses the internet soon failed with
pictures of hospitals at breaking point
and the body bags piling up on buses
images brought to the world by citizen
journalists risking life and liberty
mob you would I'm not even scared of
death you think I'm afraid of the
Communist Party
China scrambled its massive resources in
the most ambitious containment efforts
ever seen - Tom this is something all
Chinese people are involved in each
person will pitch in and will play their
part thank you jack
health workers from across China headed
to the frontlines of the outbreak
putting themselves in harm's way
of course we're worried and so are our
relatives but we're nurses and we'll do
our job as long as we wear the uniform
the scope of China's response is
unprecedented new medical centers built
in days universal temperature monitoring
controversial strict social distancing
rules that included locking down a city
of millions helping to stop the spread
and meticulous contact tracing and Wuhan
10,000 epidemiologists aggressively
traced every person that a coronavirus
patient had been in contact with
hundreds of thousands were tested at
fever clinics like this
scientists returning from a fact-finding
mission praised the efforts folks this
is a rapidly escalating epidemic in
different places that we've got to
tackle super fast to prevent a pen that
I mean it's it's actually what China
demonstrates is where this goes is
within the control of our decisions to
apply this kind of rigor and approach -
- to this disease experts say the China
PlayBook is a blueprint for the world
but the question is can be and will they
follow it
professor Dale Fisher from the National
University of Singapore and he was part
of the whu-oh team that visited China in
February professor Fisher thank you for
joining us the report commends China for
the kind of response it had to the
corona virus outbreak my question to you
is is the world ready to follow the
China PlayBook oh that's a good question
bearish um in fact one of our comments
was that we had major concerns over
whether the world was ready some of the
interventions that were required in
China really required a lot of community
engagement and a lot of thoroughness
speed decisiveness and we thought some
countries could struggle would you like
to name these countries is most of the
world ready to follow the China response
you know the world is full of countries
with completely different contexts so so
you know I think the the countries that
are being taken by surprise er you know
the the ones with many cases at the
moment you know in many ways the unlucky
ones they were the first ones tested and
more and more now that people can see
what happened in Italy which is not
completely different to what happened in
Wuhan compared to what's happening in in
Iran South Korea
you know these countries were tested
very early and and other countries I
think have got the opportunity to learn
from what happened in China but also
from what's happening in these other
countries and and try and have the
preparedness in place so that so that
they don't follow likewise much along
the lines of China Italy has effectively
imposed a nationwide lockdown would you
say that based on the current situation
of the number of cases worldwide that
there are other countries that should
have potentially imposed a lockdown by
now and they haven't it's it's really
about whether you're able to bring in
the interventions
one of the major interventions is early
case detection and and identifying the
contacts and being able to follow them
up closely enough so that if their case
if they become cases then we can stop
that chain of transmission because
they've been identified early and indeed
in many cases isolated even before the
symptoms began so you need to have sort
of these more drastic measures such as
lock downs I think when the number gets
to the point that you physically can't
track everybody anymore so it's like
stay still because we can't follow you
what would that number be it completely
depends on the context the resources the
size of the country the mobility of the
population if if you know I would I
would argue that Europe's a very mobile
population there's a lot of easy
transport and and it really wouldn't
take and indeed hasn't taken long for it
to spread across Europe so there does
get to a point where you just have to
ask people to stay home until we can
till we can control the spread
how would you read the European response
so far as you correctly point out
mobility within Europe is another matter
compared to say some of the other
countries in the world border controls
don't exist would you say
European response has so far been
satisfactory I wouldn't like to say it's
been satisfactory or unsatisfactory you
know every country has different
challenges and China has the capacity to
to to act swiftly and and with with
great sort of decisiveness other
countries have to work with their
population and while some countries may
like to make these decisive decisions
early the population has to be ready for
it to be accepted so you know I wouldn't
like to speculate on on the timing but
you know clearly I think as opposed to a
few weeks ago the world is much more
awake and of course we might have
preferred that the world was more
prepared a couple of weeks earlier but
you know it is what it is and that and
now you have to to act you know China
bought the world a lead time and
different countries use that lead time
to varying degrees this was declared a
fake on January the 30th the public
health emergency of international
concern
the w-h-o can't scream louder than than
this is a fake and I think and I hope
countries were moving as quickly as they
could from that time to be prepared
would you say countries are moving as
fast as they potentially should have
been it's difficult for me to say you
know I'm not in all those countries I
think some countries as you know I live
in Singapore this country move very
swiftly to implement and by the time we
had cases all our major hospitals could
do testing we were able to pull an extra
support to do the contact tracing
we had quarantine you know the capacity
to to quarantine people with an
electronic surveillance systems you know
it these could be in place to make sure
people were adhering to the
I know because when I came back from
China I was in quarantine and I was
getting twice daily phone messages that
I had to answer where they would they
could like take my phone to make sure
that I was in my address so these simple
measures are in place in some countries
other countries might have to do them a
bit more manually but this is the
preparedness I'm talking about you know
for some countries it would be very
challenging and and and I can see them
all scouring I don't hear as much
bravado and and discussion like that
anymore I think every country is now
taking it very seriously just as a final
question if there were certain measures
you would recommend to governments
around the world which would those
measures be that should definitely be
followed in the event of coronavirus
outbreaks so it might surprise you to
hear my answer but to me the biggest
measure is community engagement if the
community is not on board with the
response then then this can't be work
the solution is in the community and
that's because spread occurs through the
community and if people don't have that
that sort of social responsibility to be
part of the solution then any government
is going to struggle governments need to
provide the the contact tracing and the
and the the overall surveillance the
enhanced approach to testing the easy
availability of testing
ideally free testing but but governments
can do that but it's the communities
that need to have to say okay when I'm
sick I'm not going to go out but if I do
have to go out I'm gonna wear a mask and
I'm gonna cough into my elbow and I'm
gonna wash my hands frequently and I'm
gonna stay away from from people as much
as I can and I'm not going to go indoors
to large large gatherings because that's
where a lot of these sort of larger
outbreaks occur professor Dale Fisher
we'll have to leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much
joining us my pleasure thanks